you don't think they have your best
interest in mind hell no bro now the
thieves have gotten so brazen they just
go in and get whatever they want and
leave right every day every day how does
it feel being in the city
recall gavin newsom though huh oh yeah
this guy sucks
not really tinder over here
what do you think is going on man you
think we're getting played somehow
yeah
and one cop told me do not trust the
city's numbers of crime the biggest fear
state i've seen society
downtown san francisco
golden gate
bridge very beautiful city san francisco
but in this video we're going to talk
about san francisco during the pandemic
which is well i can't say the most
beautiful environment
quite a few
interesting odd
and not so uh amazing things going on at
the moment so we're gonna go downtown
i'm gonna i'm gonna show you what i'm
talking about i'm going to explain
what's going on as a resident in the
city
and well just document history i think
it's an amazing time
to document the life cycle of the city
and hope that it's never like this again
okay here we go
okay here we are guys
downtown
very quiet place as you can see this is
saturday but midweek has been like this
also
and so i just want to touch on some a
few points
observations i've had by living here
my wife and i moved back to the u.s
didn't plan on staying but uh
well kova does interesting things to
people's lives so
we're here living in the city
lived here before was gone for four
years
and i want to go into some of the some
of the main topics here
that i've observed
during my time here in san francisco the
first thing i would say would be fear
there is
like if the goal is to make people
scared
uh well mission accomplished that's for
sure
there's a lot of fear pulsating through
the society here so for example
you know i'm around nobody right now so
i'm not wearing a mask but outside
uh everyone's wearing a mask for the
most part and especially when they get
close
and so
you know you put up your mask
and literally
um you know i could be here
someone's over there
we both have masks on
and they're they're doing this they're
they're they're going away from you and
just this look down just look down this
this
paranoid
vibe
so of all the places i've been in the
world 85 countries to be exact i lived
over season four
this is uh
been the biggest fear state i've seen
society in and i'm i'm comparing with
you know afghan tajikistan border 2002
when they're
uh drug lords getting heroin
over the uh over the river and the the
tajik troops and the russian troops were
hunkered in
and honestly society in that part of the
world
had less anxiety and fear in it
than san francisco during coven i get
the
seriousness of this pandemic
i understand
a lot of people's lives are at risk but
what i don't understand is the fact that
you know we're in this together we don't
have to be so
um just scared of each other i mean it's
even gotten to the point on hiking
trails my wife doesn't want to go on the
trail behind our house because
people look at you like literally a
threat
and
you know that's with distance and a mask
on
so pooping anywhere is basically legal
because there's no enforcement for
defecating on the street i'm not trying
to gross you out here that's why i
blurted out but i just want to show you
that
feces in urine
all over the place down here so the city
decided to be a great idea because of
kobe kovet to shut down all the
bathrooms
so if you're gonna
try to use the restroom say i think
california pizza kitchen is open for
takeout if you want to use the restroom
not happening coffee shop not happening
so they're pretty
much uh no no restrooms
in in the in the center of a major city
i mean there might be a few public ones
i can't imagine what those look like
so
nowhere to go to the
bathroom because of covid
this is market street and over here to
the left is cvs
for those that don't know it's a
drugstore
and years back a few years back prop 47
came into law which basically uh made it
a misdemeanor instead of a felony to
steal up to 950 dollars
worth of whatever from say a cvs
walgreens
any store
and so what's going on now is
uh since the crime has increased in the
city
the cops are very busy
with that you have people going in to
these stores
every day of the week so the walgreens
where i live
every day of the week they say
people are going in and stealing so they
grab up to 950
worth or whatever put it in a bag walk
out now here's where it gets very
interesting and almost unbelievable if
the employee says anything
to the criminal
uh stop or tries to stop them or tries
to confiscate the stolen goods the
employee will get fired this is what
i've told at walgreens now i don't want
to show any of these people on at my
local walgreens they're all fantastic
great people but they can't be on camera
we're now in a society where looting is
incentivized the da's not punishing
people for these lower level crimes
so the cops are catching people they're
back on the street the next day catch it
and get catch them again back on the
street you do it enough times and they
become they become demoralized
where they don't really bother with it
everyone just looks the other way now
the thieves have gotten so brazen
they've actually
they actually can steal
go to the front counter and try to
return without a receipt because they
never bought anything
and try to get cash back
okay so what does this do to society
what does this do to the mentality of
these people
working at these shops
during the cove at times they're the
ones being exposed everything they're
not making a ton of money at walgreens
or cvs and anyone can just walk in and
take
you know and they can't they can't even
look at the person they're instructed by
their employers not to even look at the
thief
and because of this
crime is
on the up big time
because there are no consequences who
would have thought if you don't enforce
this stuff that uh
that it would actually get worse instead
of better
but they can they just go in and get
whatever they want and leave right every
day every day i want i do agree you
can't stop them yeah you can or can't no
stopping those though
no ah man
so the
employees are
upset i'm sure yeah we call the police
every day what are the police there what
is the police
they come they come okay but
can't do much huh later later
i'm sorry man this is ridiculous
what what a crazy world huh yeah
like how is this possible
like we're told you can go in and take
things and then and then leave and no
consequences
oh yeah yeah
you're infringing on my rights i'm
allowed to take 950 dollars with
whatever
wow that's some great logic
all right bro what's your name moses
moses
peter
i'm just gonna take 950 or whatever
okay
so it's it's it's honestly that insane
that's it's not a joke i'm not making
this stuff you'd think you'd think this
should be made up but no so you heard it
from the man
and it's really been hard to get people
to talk i haven't wanted to push it
because
the walgreens in my neighborhood
such sweet people such nice people and
they're like really some of the coolest
to people to people to talk to these
days during the pandemic they just
they're just real the psychology behind
you know not being able to stop people
from stealing
where you work
day in day out
has got to be heavy and
no one's representing these people
that's for sure
nice civil store some jack johnson
playing
you know but hey
take what you want
so i'm not trying to be hard on the cops
because the guy said the cops come
and they don't really do anything and
they've been i think their hands are
tied
these days i don't know if there's been
actual defunding but there's a lot of
talk and the cops from the ones i've
spoken to just i i talk to ones on the
street sometimes obviously they're not
going to be on camera
these days
they're highly demoralized
and one cop told me
he said
do not trust the numbers how about that
do not trust the city's numbers
of crime
and okay that that sounds not credible
because i just said some guy told me
that some cop told me that sort of like
when people say sources said
you know all most mainstream
media always uses sources said which
means absolutely nothing
but this is honestly from my
just talking with people uh and trying
to understand this place right now
so yeah cops like don't trust the
numbers crime's way up i said why don't
you quit you're demoralized
your job's sucking way more
he said a couple years i'm out of here
going to retire
counting every day down
so
i hope not all cops are feeling that way
at the moment
because i've been to places where
there is no honest policing
and
uh the police don't have much control of
society that's not a healthy society
that's
not a lot of fun
uh
because there's some other force that
comes in and
fills the vacuum
we obviously want good policing that's
the goal but
uh demoralized cops in the city
not healthy coming up on tenderloin now
tenderloin's up here a little bit more
we'll poke in a bit tenderloin is
notorious for
just being a little bit of a rougher
neighborhood
actually a lot rougher so what the
city's also been doing is putting a lot
of homeless in uh
hotels because there are no tourists
here right now so the city's been saying
you know let's let's put these people in
hotels i forget what the program's
called
uh so thousands of homeless are in
hotels with that said there's still a
ton on the streets
and a lot don't want to go in the hotels
because i think they're rules that go
along with it
or on the streets
if you're an attic
you can use your needles
do whatever you want
power of the dead idols which you
worship the idols of money the idols
of fame the idols of sex the idols of
adultery
anything that you put before god you are
making a god humble yourself
he's a great speaker
here's a statistic a san francisco
statistic for you last year
699
overdose deaths in the city
and 235
covet deaths
so what's that basically three times
as many overdoses as kovac does
they really got some bad cop cars
look at these things
they're beat up
all right
so here's wes
westfield popular downtown
mall
and the interesting thing is is the the
city decided that that this is cool now
they say i think 30 or something i'm not
sure the percentage but
i've been in here and it's been pretty
busy i don't think they're really
monitoring it
but restaurants
outdoor dining
which there have been no studies
in the city
claiming that that's spreading kovid
are closed
so all the the beautiful
soulful businesses of this city
have been
uh well just choked out
hello
you can't do the outside thing at a
restaurant
but you can walk inside to a mall look
i'm all for this being opened i'm not
saying shut this down i just feel like
it's hard
judgment on the restaurants
we got what's going on here recall go
what's going on here
recall gavin newsom though huh hell yeah
this guy sucks get him out french
laundry they're just that the whole
thing and the guy is so
into himself and his own ascendance to
uh the president
oh yeah he's just in more corruption do
you think he's got a chance
no
yeah it seems like a lot of our
politicians don't really have any of our
interests in mind you haven't yet
yeah it doesn't matter right this is a
bipartisan effort all the way oh really
oh god yes i'm a dem
san francisco born and raised i believe
that he
is bringing california down
intentionally intentionally destroying
small business because yeah that's true
these closures have been arbitrary the
westfield mall behind you is open right
now all day long it's just over there
yeah restaurants are all costco you name
it these big box places they're the big
business they're going to last they want
to wipe out entrepreneurship they don't
want the middle class
they don't want them dependent on
the big guys okay people who are trying
to make a living raise their families
take care of themselves do what's right
they're taxpayers too they're wiping out
an entire tax base i'll tell you that
much right as well and um
it's showing you know where the pension
where's the pension money gonna come
from keep saying they're gonna tax the
billionaires
well they're all leaving california
we've had it
as it is in this state i mean it's so
real what's going on it's just people
need to wake up
we need to wake up
what does californians need to do right
now because it's getting quite
ridiculous where it's legalized to go
steal up to 950 dollars the
the security guards can't even stop them
they're not even allowed to remember
that we are the base of the culture we
are the people we make it happen or we
let people stomp all over us so we can't
complain it's up to us and the lockdowns
right now these are indefinite from what
i know right now indefinite
oh yeah they told us that didn't they
and as a matter of fact san francisco
has never gone below 22 and i see your
availability for uh well over a month
it's been probably about six weeks since
yes
all right
so how many how many uh signatures do
you guys have well it's over 1.1 million
how many do you need 1.5 wow i was
thinking of doing the same thing but
here i'm supporting i really was this
guy he stole his soul you don't think
they have your best interest in mind
so guys i didn't expect to run into this
i i thought it was going to be empty
down here and it's actually there's some
life and there's and there's some real p
there's some real people
it feels nice to look at people in my
neighborhood nobody's looking at each
other right they've fallen asleep it's
they're all scared here they got the
devil's fear
they got so much fun bro they shine up
thank you good luck in everything you do
wow guys so just a conversation is like
uh i got chills
because it hasn't happened it's not
happening in this city but downtown it
actually is
so here we have anti-abortion
and again my content guys for those that
watch my videos
i show what i see
you make your decision i'm not telling
you what to think
so tension for sure
she said if they rape us we got a
[ __ ] choice
i love this
about america is that
the peaceful protest peaceful protest is
beautiful
we would have died we would have got
shot look at this are they getting shot
the police aren't leading are they
getting paid
no no it looks it looks chill
and we were just as peaceful as they
were
what you got you got you guys walked
down here the same way like the same
thing happened with you guys
down the street okay i did protest in a
couple of different things oh it's for
myself yeah you're supposed to
i am i'm posting all this yeah
yeah yeah yeah
how does it feel being in the city
this is obviously a tense issue
tense issue
you're gonna walk get back to the theme
of the video well this is sort of the
theme of the video covet during uh
san francisco during covet times
all right
what's your name i'm jason jason yes so
what you're saying you were just saying
what i was saying that has been the
apocalypse since march of 2020 and the
world is starting to come to an end all
of a sudden
and it's been ghost town in san
francisco it's very unusual to see
nobody really out here like that right
kind of have a little bit of life
you know it's kind of like a protest
going on yeah that was just even if you
don't agree with it or you agree with
whatever it's just good to see like
people you know what i mean he's
representing seeing people again
so what's crime doing around here do you
have any beat on that do you know what's
going on
as far as prime this is the tenderloin
even though it's tenderloin there's
nothing really tender over here
but uh it's not it's not for the soft
people huh
people from my neighborhood are not
coming down here that's for sure right
exactly but i'll tell you what people
are cooler here right now for some
reason than over in my neighborhood
right i'm out of the city a little
everyone's scared of [ __ ] of each other
it sucks
all right i'm from kansas city you're
from kansas city
what's that like kansas city it's a lot
more
i would say it's very different as far
as like the whole epidemic because
they're not really shut down or anything
like that i just have to wear a mask you
know make sure they're being safe but
everything out there is pretty much
still open
california new york everything's shut
down so in kansas city it's just sort of
normal life right now yeah normal life
right now what do you think's going on
man do you think we're getting played
somehow or what what's your thoughts on
that
or who knows i do i do definitely think
we are getting played look at the mini
mini bike here man right
damn what's up man
so what's going in the the tenderloin i
heard there was like uh i think it was a
week ago or two weeks there was like a
five people shot down here did you hear
about that i did it okay yeah yeah
i mean i've noticed crimes up everywhere
yeah you know
about mr said what happened you know
what happened no i just i just saw a
report
on an app
crime map killing each other our police
yeah yeah
yeah yeah
no it wasn't the police that some guy
just went loose with his gun
so do you do you notice the homelessness
on the up here or down or even or what
um
i would say if the epidemic happened it
definitely went up okay
and it was worth it was bad before
yeah
you got the beach
floodlight
you guys are living it up
the sun the music the beer
gosh you're not you're not freaking out
on life
see you guys
here we have city hall
nice little playground
and over here we have
a tent city
there are a few of these around the city
but i believe this is a place where they
set up
tents and bathrooms and
places for homeless to be
off the streets but
sort of on the street at the same time
and this city is just
it's just rife with juxtapositions it's
some of the richest people in the world
and then
some of the poorest
maybe not the world but in the country
for sure like some of the more down and
outs
uh people
hard on their luck
uh
and then some of the some of the
wealthiest
it's weird
uh
city's got all sorts of problems
and you know i think the pandemic just
like they're always here
but it it put the spotlight on
everything
it gave it a 10x
uh feel
and so when things open up you know say
the vaccine goes through the population
the restaurants open back up again
and uh the lights are on basically right
and we have all the business activity
and all the all the life on the streets
again
maybe this problem quiets down again but
i do feel like it's like a
like a loud refrigerator which means
it'll always be humming in the
background
and it needs to be addressed there's
something fundamentally wrong
here right now
with the pandemic and just the
the dynamic of this place
retail space
plenty of it
across the street
empty
ecuador coffee sounds a good place
warfield
a lot of jesus
people down here a lot of recall gavin
newsom people
and some street music this is fantastic
been missing this
thank you for being out here we need
street music so bad like mrs stuff
oh thank you yeah take care good luck
here we are in pacific heights one of
the wealthiest neighborhoods in the city
and while that video did not go
as according to plan
i was
going to show you what i've been feeling
here which is this
pervasive fear
in society
and it was actually
more people out
out and about and smiling and looking at
one another
in the center of the city than
in my neighborhood that's for sure
oh well
it was interesting
good to see what this city is doing
right now you can see it's low
it's on its knees a bit so
let's uh let's hope this place turns
around
in time because it's
it could go worse
but let's hope not
okay until the next one oh and if you
want to support this channel i have a
patreon page
down below a lot more videos from
around the world and i'll be doing much
more here in the states
in the uh well the upcoming year
okay thanks for coming along until the
next one
you